[Music]
this is games to know by heart tonight
we'll be looking at three of Michael
tall's games but Mihiel tall was a very
strong chess grandmaster he even became
world champion by defeating another me
hi oh I think bad Finnick and he's kind
of well-known as this attacking genius
and he sacrifices all of all of his
pieces his nickname was the magician
right you know like his sacrifices were
unsound but in all the complications
basically nobody nobody could figure
figure them out over the board so he
would win a lot of games but I I think
that a lot of people just underestimate
how strong he was a positional chess and
his his whole understanding for the game
so we're gonna look at three of his
games where he demonstrates not just his
tactical ability abilities but well his
ability that of strategic play and
positional play in general so tall is a
saying the white pieces against
gentlemen named Vladimir 7 e 6 Knight c3
D 5 D 4 so this is very topical nowadays
this is a very I mean this is the
traditional Queens gambit declined this
is this is played at the highest level
and the lowest level like like this will
never be refuted I think that the best
move here is probably the move Bishop to
e7 but black played Knight to f6 which
is the other main move and here tall
plays may be the reason why the move
Knight f6 could be considered an
accurate he took on d5 and after takes
on d5 he plays the move Bishop to g5
now here black plays Bishop e7 there's
the short variation which is C 6 and
after e3 there's special about 5 this
was very common a few years ago until
the game between Carlson and Kramnik now
nobody plays us anymore because it's
basically basically just considered good
for good for white although for a very
long period of time they thought this
was just equal maybe you know a few
months from now they'll think that this
is equal again so who knows but that's
that's the state of modern theory anyway
this was a long time ago so you'll have
to excuse their theoretical knowledge of
today's games anyway Bishop e7 e three
castles Bishop d3 now what we've note
what you can notice so far or two things
not not what the players have done but
rather what they have not done what had
well why does not develop his knight
right because it's not clear if his
knight wants to be on f3 or e2 and what
black is not done she hasn't committed
his pawn from c7 to c6 or to c5 so
they're kind of feeling each other out
right it's not it's not at all clear
what black wants to do is not clear
white wants to do they're they're just
kind of playing chess this position in
97 is is one of the main moves Knight f3
Knight f3 is probably a little bit
inaccurate for from a modern standpoint
it used to be considered a very long
time ago these types of positions were
just good for black why because it was
some the the consensus that white has to
Center pawns which they didn't fully
appreciate but black had a black spawn
chain is pointed towards the Kings side
right I think this was the mindset and
like you know the 1800s or something but
basically they knew that the pawn chains
were important so black black has the
majority on the Queen side and as pawn
chain points towards the Kings side
therefore black can play on the Kings
side
right and why it's gonna play on the
queenside but they didn't see how white
could use his majority right but what
they failed to fully appreciate and this
is a very common idea is that because
white pawns are pointed towards the
Queen side white has the idea of playing
for the minority attack with rook b1 b4
and b5 right there there are a few other
lectures on the st. Louis site that go
over them minority attack and and a lot
more detail but that's basically
basically what changed the the opinion
from well this is just good for black to
this is probably good for white and a
lot of people actually started playing
this with with the white pieces and
people stopped playing this for black
for a while then they kind of realized
that after after the Knights committed
to f3 c6 if if black plays kind of in
normal fashion let's say rook e8 Queen
c2 he has a lot of pluses like knight
Knight to f8 if you play something like
rook b1 then I can play the move Knight
to g6 you go before I go a six if you go
away for play Bishop d6 and you you can
achieve some kind of weakness on c6
right this is like the minority attack
now we have a weakness to target with
white but in exchange for that black is
very active he has the a file and the
position is roughly balanced so that was
that that was what what they they were
thinking of course during the time of
this game they didn't they didn't come
to that conclusion yet but then they
then I think is far off although maybe
some other players started playing in
the fashion of putting their night on e
to with the idea that not only do they
have the idea potentially of going B 1 B
4 B 5 but they also have another idea of
going F 3 and E 4 which is an expansion
in the center so that's another plan
that White has his disposal right and
probably why it is better if he puts his
night on e 2 so I think that the move
Knight of three is a slight mistake
but rookie a notice black still hasn't
moved to see pawn he hasn't made any
commitments
maybe he'll play c5 maybe he'll play c6
it's not at all clear
castles Knight of fate Queen c2 so if
you give black two moves black wants to
play c6 and he wants to play Bishop g4
because in this position blacks problem
piece is the bishop on c8 if he can get
rid of that then he has no bad pieces
potentially he also wants to play the
move 94 and he wants to liquidate some
of some of the white pieces and he will
equalize out of the opening with very
few problems this is a very safe opening
for black because if you mess up then
you'll be worse right normally like if
you play the Grune fell over the King's
Indian if you mess up you get made it or
you lose all your pieces right in the
Queens gambit if you mess up like some
slight move order or something you're
never lost you're just like so you know
like Wars or maybe significantly worse
so that's the benefit of playing this
type of opening with black is the margin
of error is kind of is kind of lower so
I were sorry yeah lower so Queen c2 is
play it's so that the move Bishop g4 can
be met with the move Knight to e5 now
that the Queen's not on d1 so Bishop e6
was played in 95-97
and Bishop to f4 so here probably what
white should do is he should take 27 and
after Queen e7 he should go f4 and now
that now that black's pieces are kind of
awkward on the Kings side this is where
white should play even though he doesn't
have a majority or anything but he can
he has better pieces right like my
bishop has a clear view of h7 maybe I
can play on the Kings side with g4 and
f5 I have definite pluses but what Saul
did is also good push it in to f4 I'm
sorry
he he maintains a very slight advantage
95 but should be 5 it's very important
to take back with the bishop this is not
a structure that you would voluntarily
give yourself because you would allow
the move c7 to c5
here's c6 was played now that black
realizes that there's no benefit of
moving his pawn to c5 you may as well
play c6 white plays the move Knight a4
I'm not sure what the arrow g 4h wife
actually means oh yeah actually I
remember
so what black should do here black plays
f6 this is a mistake because never play
of 6 right well known been Feingold rule
but what would what would you guys do
with the black pieces so imagine you're
playing a world-class Grandmaster right
you're sitting across from him you're
like well I don't want to lose so what
what do I do a six a six is one of those
moves you don't really want to play
voluntarily right so there's nothing
like tactically wrong with a six
immediately this may be a fine move but
sorry oh yeah so here here's the two
problems pawns can never move backward
in check and backwards in chess right so
whenever you push a pawn
you know you've created some kind of
weakness so yeah so the pawn on 8a seven
protects b6 right
you will never protect b6 for the rest
of this game right that with the pawn
and that's that's kind of unfortunate
because b6 is a very important square
especially if the Knights on a four
because it's immediately threatening in
some positions to go to b6 and you don't
want to play the move b5 for the same
reason because let's say I just move my
knight
okay the c5 or c3 doesn't matter the c6
pawn will be weak for the rest of the
game because none of its colleagues will
be able to protect it right so those
moves you shouldn't be trying to play a
six or or or b5 just because you leave
some weaknesses behind even if they
might bring some tactical justification
in
yes yes that's correct
that's what blacks should do here black
should play the move Bishop to g4 and
you should try to play Bishop h5 to g6
and this is very decent equalizing
chances because black is if black
manages trade off these bishops right
then all of a sudden whites Queen sight
expedition will become a lot less
desirable also the reason why I don't
like the move in the game f6 is because
the same reason why a six and B five
right I don't like is now what black
will never be able to protect the e6
square he thinks that it doesn't matter
and maybe he's right I mean he's a lot
stronger than than I am but it's one of
those things that doesn't make me it
doesn't make me feel good
but yeah so f6 Bishop just goes back to
g3 Black's created a lot a lot of
weaknesses or around the the keen side
just by playing the move f6 Bishop f7 he
wants the same thing right
so he went black with Bishop g4 and
Bishop t6h fighter g6 he wants to do
this and the reason why I played f6 is
he wants to do it faster right the
problem isn't just weakens u6 in the in
the process b4 so what what is this
month is white crazy
sorry
well yes right and then the the minority
attack you want to play b5 but now the
simpleton that I am the first thing that
I that I have to ask myself is well why
can't I take the pawn alright so what
would you do here with the white pieces
because if you play b4 and your opponent
can just take them b4 like that's the
refutation you don't play before so you
need to have something here white rook F
sorry yeah Oh which would wreck Huayra K
or white rook F why okay why do you want
to play this rook to able to be one as
opposed to this rook you have two rooks
that can go to be one which would and
why
cláudio suggested rook F to be one right
presumably because after a5 you wanted
to play a3 yeah see he kept his work on
a1 now that the bishop now that the
pawns on a5 he noticed that this was
blacks only way to kind of consolidate
his pieces so now now that when this
position happens his rook is protecting
the pawn on a three so if the bishop
moves away White has already succeeded
in the minority attack because the
pollen to c6 is a weakness right so it's
one of those things like it looks like
the rook on a1 is trapped but it turns
out that you need this resource a2 a3 so
it's better to play rook F to b1 and
that's that certainly would have been
Michael tall's reaction however a black
is a good player so he didn't take on
before he played Bishop d6 rook to be
one Bishop takes g3 hg black argues that
by liquidating some of the pieces some
of the pressure will be alleviated from
the position a six a six is per is the
his sole goal is to prevent b4 to b5 the
problem with this is of course the
you're never going to want to play b6
because a six will be weak or that b6
immediately will be subject to attack
late to c5 attacks that b7 pawn rook to
e7 protects the b7 pawn a for what is
white want to do it b5 that's correct
alright so rook to c7 now we're kind of
making b5 a little bit less attractive
because my rook is x-raying your queen
through the night so if you play b5 I'll
take and play 96 right or something like
that actually that's bad because age 17
sorry what okay sorry yeah see take some
b6 my apologies yeah rook to c1 Queen to
e7 rook to b3
why did White has now defended against
this x-ray right you might not think
that it's important right because there
are two pieces in the way but the Brooke
and the Queen being on the same line is
something that you always need to think
about because if those pieces disappear
then it's not going to be good for the
Queen did the rook always wins that
fight so rook c3 and well that it's like
a Logan's gun or something right
rook to see it was played and we come to
the critical moment of the game what
would you do with the white pieces how
would you proceed how do you maximize
your advantage
the theme is in balances everybody at
home is shouting at at there you know
like TV screens or computer screens
right now that you know there's some
there's rice in the street that's
ridiculous
well what what is the first thing that
comes to mind you don't have to be right
like being right isn't the thing that
you should be concerned about here just
whatever whatever you are thinking about
it's probably us I mean if you consider
then obviously we should go over it so
even if it's not the correct answer we
can learn from it and it doesn't matter
if you get the correct answer or not
very interesting so what you've noticed
is that you can sacrifice a piece for
two pawns on the Queen side right so you
want to take with
the bishop and you want to take with the
night presumably because you're
attacking the rook now and if the rook
moves then what are you gonna do
c6 right and this is a very interesting
imbalance I will say this was not played
but what when I think you've noticed is
that you have two connected passed pawns
on the Queen side right if you manage to
continue with something like b5 b6 and
you'd be completely wedding
unfortunately I think there's a tactical
there are some tactical issues with your
position like if so imagine not tactical
issues but I've already like kind of
blockaded like if you go b5 and going b6
you have to move your knight first right
and this isn't like most testing I want
to think this is more serious this is a
really serious recommendation how do you
how do you play after this probably what
black should do is play something like
96 you can't take on d5 because of the D
a six-night if you play something like
b5 maybe black can get some counter and
play with 95 potentially or maybe some
queen a3 something like this but yeah
this is this is a very good
recommendation it's very interesting but
you might have something even stronger
than this but it is it is very similar
to your theme you do want to sacrifice a
piece on the for those two Queen side
pawns my name would be seven and a six
the question is how do you do it
that is correct
90 xb7 the reason why this is a better
way is because you you actually went in
exchange through this process rather
than just you know and this is
completely winning yeah so this this
happened in the game rook to a8 takes
takes Queen goes to be three c6 is
hanging and it's permanently week okay
six be five takes seemingly what White
has done is really silly because he's
gotten rid of blacks weakness for free
but he attacks likes Queen Queen b6
eight takes rook a5 rook c6 takes takes
takes it's not really possible to move
away the pawns just way too strong and
that's assuming that something like rook
C rook c8 and rook f6 doesn't you know
immediately seal the deal so Queen b5
was played takes takes and rook f6 f7
taining you move f7 rook c8 and well
black immediately loses one of his
pieces back and well he resigned here so
that was that was kind of nice right all
white all white had to do right
so why developed his pieces to normal
squares he played Bishop g5 he put his
Bishop on d3 play Knight f3 then he just
knew that the minority attack was was
something that he was he was aiming for
in the structure so know whenever the
structure happens you know when you have
these two pawns against these four pawns
you're the main idea and the position is
to go b4 and b5 so he knew that and what
and then he put all of his pieces on the
C file and the pressure was too much and
black played a mistake
the losing the losing move because black
can suffer here black can play some
other move like rook da it's not good
but it's not lost and even I take even
bishop takes a sixes as a serious move
and Knight takes b7 is completely
winning so tall tall with the white
pieces against Frank
Reimer d4 f5 tall plate Knight f3 so
this is the Dutch defense Knight of
three is kind of known to be inaccurate
nowadays because there are certain Dutch
systems where the Knights actually
better on h3 not to go too much in
theoretical depth but you know like in
the Stonewall systems if you want to
trade your bishop your the dark squared
bishop soph it's better to have the
knight on h3 so that you defend f4 but
903 is also a perfectly fine move
especially because of what what tall
played here which is an anti Dutch so
he's not actually going for any of the
main lines he plays the move Bishop g5
yeah
so what black play 94 which violates an
opening principle what is the opening
principle that this violates right don't
move the same piece twice yes it's not
something that you want to do because
obviously if your opponent develops
their entire army entire army while you
are moving the same piece over and over
and over again then you're gonna have a
lot of problems so 94 a slight violation
of this h4 like whoa what's that right
but
all right so black actually has a threat
here right so you might think well 94
violation of this principle I kind of
agree with but at the same time if you
pass right like a three that's a past
move Knight takes d5 Knight takes d5 and
something like e five it doesn't matter
well okay
e five black black has the bishop pair
and the knight on d5 is loose so he's
gained a lot of time in the opening
namely because white played the move a
283 but anyway the move H 2 to H 4 is
played specifically against this move
Knight takes e5 which he played h6 g5
and now we've opened up our rook and we
fixed this pawn structure so my pawn on
g5 makes sure that whenever you play h6
there's going to be something week on h6
so this is now an isolated pawn right
that's a long-term strategic weakness so
the the fact that I've played h6 g5 my
rook is now active I have more control I
have I have a lot more space because I
control some of my opponent's territory
and well basically White has a huge
advantage already out of the opening 94
and 96 g5 is a little suspicious g6
Knight c3 so why Knight c3 tall wants to
play the move e to e4 and well he wants
to either a weak in black structure by
making him take back with a G pawn
because black is really weak on this
side he wants to open up the center
because he's ahead in development and
that's what you want to do when you're
you're ahead in development and
potentially if his opponent stops him
which he does because you can't allow
your opponent to play E to to e4 that's
just not something that you can tolerate
his knight from c3 can end up on the f4
square which would be highly
advantageous putting pressure on the g6
point it's just it's
it's an outpost a very nice square on a
for Queen d2 Bishop g7 Queen F for first
tall wants to put his queen on the
kingside where a might have more
contribution than on d1 he makes he
makes the move Queen d2 Queen a4 before
he opens up the route for the night he
castles Queen side Quinn d6 g3 this
would be a terrible move this is
something that this is strategic death
right you're never going to be able to
play u5 I will play e3 none of black's
pieces can move the bishop on g7 is a
glorified pawn this is this is not
something that you can tolerate with
black so Queen d6 is played namely so
that if if white not to say the Queen 66
is a bad move but if white plays Queen
takes c6 he takes c6 at least we have
more control over the e5 pawn I sorry
five square so g3 Bishop e6 III 97
Bishop goes to d3 so why does developed
all of his pieces bishop to go step 7 we
take on d6 now takes and rook h4 we want
to put our other rook own h1 and target
the age 7 pawn and we want to put our 9
enough for so 92079 of 4 so now we come
to a very interesting point in the
position now if I had this in a
tournament game I would be very happy
but it also be very concerned with the
white pieces that I have reached like my
maximum potential because it seems like
all of White's pieces are on perfect
squares and I don't see an immediate way
to win which is something very dangerous
because if your pieces are on their best
squares and you're not winning then
there's something wrong with your
position so what what what should white
be aiming for what's the move that the
whites should be aiming for in this
position the pawn break
first of all okay wears white stronger
on the Kings side or the Queen side keen
side yeah very obviously right yeah all
the whites pieces are on the Kings side
so white is stronger on the Kings side
not to mention you have a pollen g5u I
actually have a majority on the
considering so why does stronger on the
Kings side so we want to play on the
King side we've identified where we want
to play so which specific pawn breaks do
we want to play for we want do we want
to play for this this move e to to e4 or
this move g3 to g4 we can play for both
it seems ludicrous to play for e4 but if
my pawn were on f3 the need for it looks
very you know like serious so which
which one would you rather have
right so you want to play the move g2 to
g4 because if you play e2 e3 to e for at
some point then you're also opening up
like blacks blacks pieces so the bishop
on e6 won't look so stupid if he four
eventually happens so that's what tall
play for the place where he puts his
rook on it on the H file first but
eventually someone who reigned the
Knights he will I mean he wants another
Knight to be on the circuit the thing
that he wants to play for is the move in
g3 g4 black plays this move Bishop e5
and this is actually a very instructive
move now black lost this game but Bishop
e5 shows that he's a strong player like
he understands what's important sorry
the the bishop the bishop on g7 does
very little however if black is sorry if
white takes on e5 and black takes back
this position may or may not be winning
but that's an imposing Center right and
let's say whites and I even just play
something like 90 to c5 you know you can
you can imagine that this position could
turn in blacks favor very very quickly
sorry
if I start efore oh yeah yeah this this
this this is this is not something that
I do though because this weakens all the
squares right yeah so also I mean yeah
also black can win material back
immediately but honestly this is
something maybe I would be a little bit
more scared of yeah yeah yeah yeah like
I have it's something that you
definitely have to be afraid afraid of
so that's tall didn't want anything to
do with that he just plays the move g3
g4 takes and takes and already here
black is lost
this is strategically lost for black
blacks rook on h8 is a tactical
liability he white has already achieved
the moved sheet g4
one thing that I forgot so I guess I
went over this a little too quickly if F
takes G for what will white play you the
tactic in a year the tactical you'll in
the room what do you what would blow I
play here yes and your point and your
point is so now we can combine ideas no
then I take f4 there you go yeah
so let's combine the two ideas right so
first we take e5 and then we take g6
yeah and this is completely winning for
white the rook is trapped so you don't
have time to play you for if you play
you for I'll take your rook if you take
back with the knight then I take and
this is lights out so this not something
that can be played sorry
in which so takes takes you for night -
sorry I mean I'm I'm still up the
exchange so I'm up the exchange and I
have the attack it's not good all right
anyway black decided to take on our four
takes rook rook e7 once again what
happens if you know what happens if you
take on g4 you what happens
very good yes night takes you six months
there you go based on this pen all right
so Roku seven takes on half five fish
about five fish about five gf5 rook age
sex and black is in total paralysis Rick
g7 rook d6 rook d8
it's a really sad sad position to be in
goes to be a tech in all the weaknesses
on the queenside
rook g7 rook h6 not even taking b7 just
limiting White's play Aria Black's play
King goes to G 896 rook rook f7 toll
plate f4 to prevent f4 you know any
nonsense a 6 tall actually played the
move a3 which does absolutely nothing to
contribute to the position but this is
the kind of move that completely
demoralized immortalizes your opponent
you're like well I can play the move a2
a3 and black resigns like because he
can't do anything
yeah right it's like it's your move now
it's it's not good when so usually looks
what happens when there are very few
pieces on the board right like usually
it's a Kanan pawn ending or just a rook
ending or just a bishop something there
it's a double rook and double night
ending and it soaks warm here it's not
it's not a good it's not a it's not
something you should be aiming for if
you're taking notes at home being inside
one is bad alright so the third and last
game this is
this is a game between vassilisa me
solve and me hi alt all starts with C
for g6g six is by the way an indication
that maybe you would want to play the
Grunfeld Knight c3 Bishop g7 Bishop g7
is not an indication you want to play
the grid fold because it is very hard to
play the grünfeld after d4 because now
obviously d5 is is not recommended
however this allows the gingy Indian
which is c5 and Bishop takes c3 which is
something that you would have to
consider I'm not sure why it's better
here it's very unbalanced Black has a
lot of weaknesses on the Kings side and
white obviously has terrible palms on
the Queen side lots of people claim
different crazy things about this
position I'm not gonna comment but sorry
yeah yeah Jinju just feel yeah g3 was
played avoiding avoiding any any
complications like that c5 Bishop g7 and
we reach a really boring position that
being the symmetrical at the symmetrical
English b3 this is not a move that any
anybody would play nowadays what is b3
so why wants to heat in White's mind he
wants to trade the dark square Bishop
and the easiest way to easiest way to
achieve that is to play Bishop b2 and
after 97 well 9a for now we're trading
darks for bishops I think that it's not
necessarily true that blacks bishop on
g7 is his best defender or that it's
even that great of a piece but that's
what white thought so that's why I
played this way people nowadays don't
play like this but you know it's it's a
legitimate idea Bishop b2 97 94 Bishop
takes Knight takes the knight on b2 is
really funny
castles III d5 so
wait sorry a Fisher system I don't know
I don't know maybe it's possible I know
this is a Fisher Fisher had some system
where he would go g6e 697 in the closed
Sicilian I am in the English - it's
possible but yeah well maybe maybe he
learned everything from tall right
Fisher should learn from tall anyway d5
Knight goes to f3 Knight Knight f5 so
it's very clear that black is better
right black has more space in the center
Black's Knights control more scores than
white White's Knights
the only bad piece in the position for
black is the bishop on c8 and I would
argue that his counterpart on g2 is not
is not that is not that great so I think
if we if we take all of the advantages
that both sides have namely you know the
fair share of the center Black has won
that battle right piece activity I think
Black has won that battle keen safety
while black is castled white is not
castled from all of our viewers cams
which is something that you'll probably
see you know like simultaneously on
YouTube you know my recommendation in
chess is that you should Castle early
and often
yeah so I I think it's very clear that
black stands better here
castles b6 so black has aiming to solve
his one strategic problem Knight a for
Bishop goes to b7 and now the bishop
doesn't look so stupid takes on d5 it
takes on d5 d3 Queen f6
what is White's plan
some
right you try to play D for some moment
but I mean all of my pieces are on d4
right so if you do this then you're
you're going to have some weakness here
assuming that I can't take on d4 which
is yeah it's something that man so I
mean like you can you can make d4 happen
right like realistically
I just don't think you can do it without
also creating a weakness so that's
something that white should aim for so
White's going in Queen d2 is going here
sorry a 3 and B 4 this is the other
thing you wanted to do in these types of
positions so yeah white plays Queen d2
rook da rook to d1
rookie a and here if you go d4 and take
a whole bunch of times you can easily
imagine that's right the knight takes is
not what you you might want to do I
think it's better to take this way
actually and put the knight on d6 you
can see that black black can easily get
very active right what's that activity
so that's why white didn't go d4 another
thing that white can play for he's
playing to move rook b1 because
potentially he wants to go a 3 and B 496
and that goes to e1 I don't like this
move 91 I feel like if there's an
opportunity to play
mm it's hard to recommend a move for for
white here but probably I'd go something
like a 3m before just I like Claudia's
idea and it's like a 5 then I'll go back
and say okay I'm worse but you know I've
been worse before I just take it from
there but 96 91 d4 practically forces
you 4 and the bishop on g2 isn't very
good this is a very improved version of
Akane's Indian defense in Reverse so
yeah 992 f5 tall knows that he that he
wants to strike at the center he wants
to isolate this d3 pawn and because he's
all of his pieces are active if things
open up he should be the one that stands
better black white really cannot afford
to play anything other than takes f3 is
a horrible move because of anything
really but this is this is also I mean
with that when the night arrives on e5
that pieces is never leaving and yeah
you just introduced a whole a whole
bunch of new problems in the position
with have three and if you don't play f3
and you play something like rookie 1 and
I take on e4 and you're forced to take
with the pawn then black will have a
protective passed pawn on d4 so white is
basically forced to take on f5 here 95
something that maybe it's one of those
things that our reaction when somebody
takes something is that we immediately
take back right we almost don't I mean I
don't know if this is true for you guys
but for me if my opponent takes
something my knee-jerk reaction right is
like I just take back like immediately
especially in blitz like I don't know if
I'd even consider any other move besides
905 but tal recognizes that the F 3
square is something that you could play
for so after 95 if you do something
silly like sorry F 4 is not silly
like let's say takes g6 then I mean
potentially this this could be fatal
like Bishop takes you to and Queen b7
and yeah with something arriving on f3
black can I mean like where are you
going right you go here this is there's
good and there's not good this isn't
good whatever I mean also I don't I
don't see like a medium 8 but this one
is a lot of material everything ones
here so white has to be very careful of
course why can even insert this move I
think that black can you even play key
nitrate here and the same as it's true
like this variation is just waiting for
black so white plays the move f4 Knight
f3 take take and white plays rook e1
trying to say well what are you doing
right now in theory the best move is
something like Queen d7 and take stakes
and whatever this position is probably
slightly better for black like is down
upon but he has complete domination over
this diagonal and that's something that
um that is well worth upon the other
thing he has is well all of his pieces
are are completely active and so far his
opponent's pieces are not active so his
pawn deficit he's sorry well White has a
pawn but black black has compensation
like very clear compensation instead
would any of you like to guess what
Michael tall played in this position
I'll give you a hint this is tall if you
know anything about taller than sorry
he's known to sacrifice all his pieces
in crazy ways I'll flip the board all
right all right night of fire night of
five is suspicious because of rookie 7 I
think I'm not a hundred percent sure but
I'm pretty sure I think that you're not
acted not even not even in closing yeah
although you have very similar ideas at
all now this isn't technically the best
move right but after what he does he's
not like much worse it's probably it's
probably the position is probably equal
in this position blacks probably
slightly better but these are the types
of moves you should be looking for like
on your list of candidate moves Bishop
e2 Bishop e2 sorry what yeah I can't
have two probably yeah there there we go
there's there's a guy is crazy crazy
like a fox Queen e2 like whoa what's
that right takes takes ok so now that
we've found Queen e2 I will say if
anybody here finds the best move that
the computer recommends I I will be
astounded because when I saw I just had
I just laughed like there's nothing you
can do so whites a move here and be
slightly slightly better equal one of
the two he can't make up its mind
ok well well look at the complications
of just like saving your queen or
something but I mean you can save maybe
saving the Queen's right but what would
you do here it's another puzzle white to
play
all right you can pause your video at
home.i unless you're like unless you're
like 3,400 I would recommend just
watching but you know feel free sorry
Queen d1 incorrect Queen e1 Queen e1
computer recommended how many how many
times in chess is it true that when
you're Queens attacked the correct way
to respond to it is to move your queen
from a square that's attacked to another
square that's attacked all right this is
the best move that the computer
recommends and the point is if you take
on e1 then then then then I can take
back with my knight and the pollen on d3
is defendant I can take on g6 and you
know it's it's it's a position anyway I
just thought that that was amusing that
Queen e1 is the best move that the
computer recommends in the game Queen
takes e2 was played if you play
something like Queen to c1 this gets
very dangerous work g2 takes rook h2 I'm
threatening rook to h1 not to mention I
can play something like rook rook here
and rook and Knight f5 and increase the
pressure so this is also something that
you have to bear in mind before entering
this with with the white pieces so in
the game Queen e2 is played so but this
was basically just a fancy way of
trading pieces and as a result we get
some ending okay taking on g6 is
ludicrous because I just take on d3 and
you might be up material but there
there's something there's a defining
factor of this position and that is I
have a bishop and you have a knight
right well we have two knights like
those cancel each other out but I have a
bishop in you have a knight pollens are
on both sides of the board which means
that the bishop is going to out-compete
the knight in this type of position so
you you cannot you cannot play this way
Knight B to black takes back on f5 rook
e1 unfortunately this position is also
very strategically bad for the white all
of his pawns are on light squares yeah
this is long term and well we're at the
end of the game basically
well black has a decisive advantage
takes rook to e8 k Neff to rook takes
King takes Kane f8 like black fixes the
pollen da Foursquare Keenan C to Bishop
goes to a targeting air for can be three
four ships e6
notice that the bishop is cutting the
knight from any active square right that
was not the end of the game boy
why Apollo 18 a 3k knife six can be
three what white doesn't have anything
better to do than just canine three can
be three okay okay King goes to g6
pretending like humans so if you do
nothing I'm gonna go take all your pawns
right C plays through to stop me from
doing that so I'll go back I provoked a
weakness you know like like black can
take his time he puts his Bishop on this
diagonal now you have to keep keep an
eye on d3 as opposed to a 491 Bishop f1
so eight if you just move your pawn then
I will go back and take all your pawns
again it's very easy so you have to play
Knight f3 and then white has this fork
but unfortunately it doesn't matter
because all of all of whites pawns are
weak 95 takes 97 Bishop d7 protecting f5
takes a 4 and well white has to deal
with the a pawn and the only way to do
that you can't take t4 because they won
Queen kena five can be to King III 9458
c5 and c6 everything's winning tall just
played Bishop f3 okay there might be
more accurate ways to win but what do
you did is fine Bishop takes enough to
me yeah and black resigned here because
this ending is not something that okay
like whatever Keeney to take stakes if
you don't take I mean what else are you
gonna do at night eh - and then f1 takes
takes takes here you are not in time
and so I just make a queen right even if
you're in time you're losing yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah even even if white we're
afforded an extra tempo like let's say
this this position is my name so thank
you very much
this was Julian Polly cope for games to
know by heart
[Music]
you
[Music]